The joe rogan experience.
All he's doing is playing some really
crazy game that was around before he was
ever born.
He just got into it and
got really good at it.
Yeah.
The game itself,
it's bananas.
Just the stock market itself.
Just the idea that the wealth of,
of,
of a a person can vary day
by day because of confidence,
you know,
confidence,
computer,
consumer confidence in a product can
shift and change with Rico and then you
watching these numbers go up and down
like what the fuck are you even talking
about?
Most of the explanations you see,
you know,
I watched these business sites in
the market will go down and they say,
oh mark it down because of
such and such in London.
And then it's like by the
time that piece comes out,
that market's actually back up and
they're already constructing their,
you know,
let's tie market going back
up to another random feature.
You know,
it's like the,
the,
the explanations after the fact
have so little to do with whatever.
Some algorithm decided it was going to
suddenly ultra fast trade something and,
and throw the stock up.
You know,
it's like at this point it's,
it truly is.
That's the best place to see
humans combating machines
is on the marketing where
it's like there's human
traders competing with these,
that programmed algorithms and the
algorithms are certainly winning the war.
And if you look at their
screens while they're,
while they're doing it,
it is almost like code.
Like the average person
who doesn't understand it,
doesn't know what the fuck
the stock market's saying,
the symbols and the essay,
Oh and this and that and
the ones and the Zeros.
You look at all that,
you have no idea what that is.
I mean,
how has that really different than a
computer code that you're reading me?
That's essentially like a,
a way that,
uh,
people are,
are,
are tapping into this bizarre system.
I mean,
it was at one time this sort of the
price of something it had to do with some
thing,
right?
It's like there's a factory,
oh,
it's factory went slower
today in the rain.
The market will go down on that.
So it was like real,
you know,
and it's gotten certainly further and
further from whatever is going on in that
company or their earnings are the things,
you know,
it's,
it's absolutely abstracted to the point
now where people don't even invest in
companies.
Right?
Right.
You invest in something like when Facebook
went public and people bought it at
like nine in the morning,
like nine,
10 they're all pissed off,
but it hasn't gone up.
It's like,
wait a minute,
I was supposed to triple my,
well,
my wealth.
It's like,
no,
you don't.
You don't make money on the trade.
You're supposed to make
money on when you've,
when you've done it.
But you know,
now we've got,
yeah.
You know,
derivatives and derivatives of derivatives
and derivatives of derivatives of
derivatives on there,
which is just a way of kind of shrinking
the explainer for people don't know
what that means.
So if you buy a stock,
I mean,
you know,
you buy stock in you,
I hope it goes up and then
you sell it in the future.
If you'd rather make
up that time right now,
I can sell it in the future right now,
right?
I can basically sell that future sale
cause I think that sales is going to be a
good one now,
right?
I can say,
what if I did that trait?
I'm to,
I'm going to,
I'm going to have it now,
but
okay,
so what am I trading then I'm trading,
I'm trading on,
on an abstraction from what something's
to be worse at some in the future.
So it's like I'm trading on the stock
over time and then someone else will say,
well,
I'm going to trade on
the abstraction of that.
I'm going to trade on whether or not
people think the stock in the future is
going to be worth more next minute.
Then this minute it's like,
well what's that?
So basically what you're doing is
you're buying the stock over time,
over time,
you're creating these things,
these derivatives of whatever
the original investment was,
which is kind of just a derivative
of the thing because the pork belly,
this driven of the pork belly,
drifters of the derivatives,
derivatives of the derivatives of the
derivatives and the derivatives all goof
ball ever tighter ways of saying
what is pork belly going to be worth,
you know,
on February 3rd why is that illegal?
Well,
it's legal because what it,
because the economy requires it,
right?
We have a kind of money,
That has a clock in it.
It's lent into existence and has to
be paid back more than got lent out.
So our economy needs to
expand by hook or by Crook.
Somehow it has to grow in
order for it to survive.
That's just the way
central currency works.
They need to find more
surface area for the money,
more ways for people to buy stuff.
So instead of just having,
there's not enough of a company to buy.
So now we can bet on how that company
is going to do in some future gut.
We can bet on that or we can bet on that.
Right.
But what we're really doing is trying to
kind of compress all of this time right
onto like the head of a
pin so we can bet on that.
So I don't have to sit and wait,
you know,
3000 years for Facebook
to be worth something.
I can trade on his future worth now.
But the whole joke of that is
people who are trading that way,
there are these computers that
are trading faster than them.
So I put in one of my super fast,
crazy,
I'm derivative trade.
Goldman Sachs sees that order
coming in on the computer.
They're so close to the exchange,
they can execute an order before my order
even goes through based on having seen
that I was going to do
what I'm going to do.
So they can literally trade in my future.
Right.
Well I am in their past.
No,
that's,
that's digital time shifting.
I mean that's,
that sounds like it's cheating.
That's like someone like running a quick
server and they're local and then you
have like 150 paying.
Exactly.
That's bullshit.
I think so.
With the Solo Bullshit.
The irony of it is it's gotten so big,
right?
Derivative trading is bigger than regular
trading now so that the New York Stock
Exchange actually just got bought.
The exchange itself got bought
by its derivative exchange,
so it's almost just like
the proof's in the pudding.
It's like the derivative owns
the market at this point,
but that's when you get that.
How,
how could the government even ever
deny how incompetent they are?
Then they allowed that like that alone
to like someone should just like have a
broadcast on national television,
a,
you know one of those town hall sort
of events where you sit down with the,
the main people that
run the country and go,
how the fuck are you allowing this?
How are you,
you not fix this?
Why would you ever try to do
anything else before you fix this?
When they made the decision,
they genuinely thought it
would be good for business.
Let it go,
let it in the short term.
I will never understand where it all
close business people promise them,
figure it out before it got really bad.
Oh my God,
we figure it out before it got really bad.
How much bigger is the derivative economy?
I don't know exactly.
I mean it seemed,
I was looking trying
to find out what that,
what the sort of trading was.
It seemed from what I could tell like
94% of trades are now derivative because
they're,
because,
because there's such bigger volumes.
God that's insane.
No one's gonna like
you're not going to buy,
you know,
10,000 chairs of Honeywell
today cause that's,
you know,
whatever.
$60,000 or something.
But you could buy like 10,000 futures
on Honeywell cause they're really cheap.
God that is so crazy.
4% of the stuff of trades are,
and how many more is,
I think it's ultra fast
too is a whole other,
there's sort of two different,
two different realms.
But yeah,
it's huge.
They must all be crazy.
Everyone involved in that must know
that they're bringing on the matrix.
They must know that they're there.
They're the first steps before
the digital machine takes over.
They must know.
They must know that there's no
humanity in that stock market shit.
That's chaos.
And,
and again,
I don't want digital technology
to get blamed for this,
right?
Because the real operating
system they're promoting,
it's not the digital operating system,
it's the economic operating
system underneath it.
It's this 13th century central currency
interest bearing debt based economy.
And none of the guys who I
thought would get us out,
you know,
ev Williams with Twitter,
Mark Zuckerberg,
with Facebook,
the kids from Google,
right?
They're getting the,
each of them had a real shot.
Even Bill Gates at breaking
the central economy and,
and flipping things the other way.
How do you go and do that?
Going public,
not be good,
not doing it with venture
capital saying if I can,
if,
if Google can hack web search,
if Facebook can hack social,
if Twitter can hack everybody,
why can't they,
you know,
they're so busy disintermediating
all these different things.
Why doesn't anyone of them yet want to
disintermediate central banking and say,
no,
Mr. Chase,
we don't actually need you.
We're going to do our whole
thing through Kickstarter.
Say like one of your
didn't want to hear things.
Uh,
yeah,
that's an interesting point of view.
I think they probably would never want
to take that stand because they would be
killed.
I would imagine there's
a lot of money and uh,
and in them not being
successful with that quest,
you know,
to control point at which,
you're doing paypal,
okay,
we're going to let people do
individual transactions that was there,
their original model and they were
going to make money on the float.
And then the banks came to them and said,
uh,
you're not allowed to do that.
You're not a bank paypal kids.
You gotta be,
you know,
can I just start as a bank or you're going
to have to be connected to one of us.
And that's when,
you know,
paypal kind of becomes part of Ebay
rather than whatever these crazy guys
might've done.
And I suppose there's this point,
you know,
where you know,
innocently these companies that
get bigger and bigger and bigger,
hoping to do the right things,
and then it's like,
we're going to,
we're going to let you
do this if you don't,
if you don't play by our rules.
But,
uh,
I also feel like there's companies that,
if you,
if you're willing to go smaller,
if you're willing to let it
grow a little bit slower,
that you can scale up,
but you can become a
big ethical corporation.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
okay.
You ready to record recording?
Oh,
it is already,
what the fuck's on?